[Musique]
diot tout excuser on serait aujourd'hui
sur un jeu a plutôt je suis au bout
parce que c'est bikini karaté peps
warriors of elysia alors il ya eu une
première version du jeu là c'est la
deuxième alors autant vous dire que bond
après un petit peu ce que vous venez de
voir et d'après cet écran de jeu vous
douter de ce que c'est moi je propose de
faire un mode arcade 1
j'aurais bien aimé savoir les touches en
gros vous allez très vite découvrir ce
que c'est que ce jeu je découvre même
temps que vous on a le choix entre
tiennent debout athena cassiopea isis
maya et a produit on va prendre mayen
tombés d'accord comprend rien
ok alors vous allez voir je vous assure
c'est un jeu créé par un gros pervers
oui c'est bien ce que vous pensez par
contre baissé c'est un jeu créé par un
gros pervers est en fait la
particularité de ce jeu c'est que vous
allez voir voilà c'est vraiment les
vraies filles sont modélisés dans le jeu
elles sont vraiment aisée dans le jeu
voilà elles font des mouvements un peu
chelou est doux et essai du stop motion
donc voila voila je me dépasse un petit
peu comme un serpent dans l'ombre un
avec un ennemi déchaîné je sais pas
comment on tape j'aimerais bien
découvrir
ok on va essayer de la battre attaque du
serpent enragé d'accord alors elles
elles font des combos on dirait que
c'est street fighter et arrête
tiens et ce qu'est ce qu'on adorait
d'une petite attaque spéciale là un
petit coup de saint séraphin mais c'est
vraiment je perds la rage m'excuser pour
ceux qui pensent que je suis un père
versée c'est pas vraiment le cas c'est
simplement que on m'a demandé mais très
casse possible
depuis quand les filles sont aussi à
j'aurais dû laisser à petit ce match et
je suis désolé même temps je vous avoue
qu'avec au joli ça non mais attends non
mais t'as vu comment elle tombe c'est
vrai c'est vrai que c'est un jeu
vachement réalise quand même un bon on
voit le double confiait dans ta face à
pro dit tiens au alors est-ce que et ce
nombre de points techniques taken on
fait toujours la [ __ ] mais la vache
mais tu arrêtes attend là je crois que
je peux me défendre en faisant ça
d'accord donc elle se fait toucher
c'est quoi mais [ __ ] d eau
vous avez vu oh là là là là oh lalala
lalala y avait tout ce qu'il y avait du
style dans cette attaque c'est la petite
roulade
on a obtenu la roue l'année on continue
on passe en mode envol je bronze
on peut revoir ça au match prouve ô
lalalalalala c'était un combat très
serré de merde bien bas d'aphrodite mais
vite alors ça c'est même problème que
dans tout le jeu de combat c'est que
personne n'ose aller au corps à corps
voilà pour ça si on a roulé de quito
tiens voilà technique tekken s'écoule à
un technique tekken alors produite je te
je tente en plus un coup dit elle génial
sectes et des coûts de bronzage est
quand même bien bel et bien de dire
tiens attaque du serpent rage et papa
papa ça depuis que j'ai découvert je
m'en lasse plus celle ci hop hop hop hop
elle marchait c'est n'importe quand même
aux rebelles alors eux saluent alors
deuxième map
qu'on cesse
oula oula lalalalalala la deuxième scène
qui veut se fight à foshan là je suis
sûr si on gagne on a une [ __ ] de
récompense à la fin une cinématique
digne des plus belles cinématiques du
monde allait bien là oh non non pas de
perdre ça me saoule parce que quand tu
joues un jeu comme ça tout un double
sens c'est horrible tiens attaque du
serpent enragé on va faire que ça hop
hop hop hop on continue rôle mais
peut-être un perfect elles peuvent être
peut rien faire elle peut rien faire ou
y a bien percé et sa rêver ce jeu alors
pour ceux qui veulent télécharger je
n'ai même pas trouvé à part en touraine
moi je vais traîner avec dora dans la
description quand même mais franchement
je l'aurais bien acheter mais j'ai même
fait je crois qu'il est sorti en 2002
en tout cas elle prend une version
sortie en 2003 et je suis pas sûr qu'il
y ait beaucoup de versions
enfin je serai sûr qu'elle soit encore
troubles on va se battre contre une
blonde audience balle dans les arbres au
milieu des sages je suis prêt là je prêt
c'est le genre de jeu auquel auquel tu
joues à deux heures puis ensuite tu m'as
la poubelle quoi tient technique du
serpent rage et voilà on va essayer de
trouver d'autres mouche quand même au
pire on sait qu'on peut gagner en
interne et du serpent rage et le poil
jeudi une de superman d'accord alors ce
que j'adore c'est qu'ils tombent quand
même un peu trop tarder un jour
j'aimerais bien lui tient bien de battre
quoi tu le saut le saut est fluide me
regarde pas mais elle va se détendre et
lun elle fait des super punch
on va attendre qu'ils arrivent on va
refaire notre âne on dit le serpent aux
urnes après la mort quand même une
petite route
j'aurais dû mettre la perruque rose
franchement j'aurais dû adapter le
creuse mais je comprends rien aux
touches par contre je crois qu
apparemment ça ça tape aussi
alors ça c'est cool j ou faire un bisou
tiens je me battre
mais c'est sur le combo que j'ai trouvé
je suis désolé c'est je sais que c'est
mauvais joueur né au world si je fais
autre chose je meurs je crois que c'est
vraiment un pur pour taper un autre
manière en fait après ça doit être des
tout genre oh mon dieu je suis vraiment
pas fort et je dois l'avouer technique
du serpent on va l'appeler la technique
du serpent tout temps ou blonde aux yeux
bleus et rigolent plus j'adore rythme et
une photo du prochain adversaire comme
c'était un truc de malade
regardez c'est tellement bien fait oh
mon dieu on a quand même pris maya on a
quand même la puissance avec nous jeter
un v6 est tombé contre une manière je
regarde juste les touches à ya les coups
de pieds et coups de pied ont offert des
coups de pied pourquoi tu nous cassent
le nez tu vois une attaque du serpent
c'est ça c'est ça ton problème et bâtir
la moelle à n'importe quoi
oh là là ça part bien statut la liberté
qui est cassé derrière moi j'aimerais
c'est un fake un cd rom as he 700 à
venger de clips qui ont voulu construire
l'après statue de la liberté absolument
n'importe quoi ce que je dis tiens hop
hop hop hop hop hop
tiens au nom mais arrête avec ça mais
comment tu fais ça
[Musique]
vient de m eh bien tu te bats femme aux
gros seins où es-tu terreur de la nuit
je ne te vois plus à part dans les clubs
dont la tiens hop je te mets le couvent
rodage le coup le coup serpent j'attends
faut qu'on trouve de combos quand même
les gens je suis désolât la tuer elle
est pas mal cela ouah ouah non non il
est maya maya 6 de maillage je sais que
tu t'enflammes beaucoup mais quand même
croit sa merde c'est bien battre ouah
ouah oh là là non non non certes on
acharnée
[Musique]
oh [ __ ] l'heure on va perdre une
chinoise il ya faut pas déconner 1 500
l'art martial
oui je sens les vieux clichés du 21e
siècle table' problème allez on y va
musique rock ou c'est la bosse on met ça
au ralenti avec une musique érotique ça
sera parfait
[Musique]
allez on y va voilà la relâche au spa
gueule je sais pas l'approcher tu fais
la bise
j'ai demandé l'avis je suis pas demandé
à copier espèce de vilaines tient prêt
donc pull up vient navire a bien là on
va mettre des coups de pieds comme ça
non non non mamadou sort des tiens cours
11 âge alors c'est en fait trop dans
cette vidéo on va retenir juste le
coupon âgées le coussin en quoi
finalement au cou serpro qui est celui
ci non mais c'est de l'autre côté maya
maya maya écoute je sais je sais que
l'excité je sais que tu aimes bien de
frapper et ça va un moment c'est 2
olalalala c'est bien la boss harrachi
c'est pourquoi c'est le calme dessus
parce que tu as des grandes jambes avec
toi mais les tiens tiens surtout enragé
tio et le petit côté pour la fin du coup
le plus ridicule de monde tout va bien
aller à les routes de route de route de
la bad ce qu'elle m'a mis il n'y a pas
d'eau touche que ça les gens je vous
assure c'est 1 et 2 les touches alors il
ya trois à d'accord 3 keller absolument
naze bien là là là
un escalier mais elle est trop forte oh
là là là là tu vas arrêter bordel
l'homme battre non terme et qui tombe
olalalala non mais là on joue contre le
boss du jeu là c'est celle à la bosse
mais l'extrême boys tient tellement à
8h30 et hauteur tout ce tourment voilà
trop tiens yes revient la regarde oui à
la technique du cerveau aura t elle
raison de nous
noël c'est le jeu le plus one on peut
tailler encore une fille
oh la la alors là on est contre la milf
la bible au milieu de crâne en pierre ou
vous
elle nous fait des pompes c'est
quelqu'un pour intimider son adversaire
qui fait des pompes à part ça tout va
bien je me sens encore un peu la musique
bien d'accord donc zéro ces prêts ont
été impliqués au tapis les skis mme hall
esquive
vous avez vu l'état contre attaque avec
la tête du serpent l'attak du la times
the little sharona instant la tête de la
bise
coucou coucou en fait c'est une fin bien
être et des pétards des ailes et elle
est forte et le 6 en fait
heureusement que on a les attaques comme
un peu de shit et avec maya maya maya c
est la meilleure non qu aller dans le
bon sens est le meilleur on se retrouve
les meilleurs
maillard [ __ ] mais maya olala elle va
gagner vu double attaque du serpent se
touchant ce nom sait pas trop bien la
times up
ce qui passe elle peut aussi s'expliquer
lui désolé mais bon j'aimerais essayer
au moins tient bien n'a jamais bien là
d'alors atteint plus tôt
tu as vu ton maillot pour eux je pense
qu'on a quand même choisi le meilleur
pas figée du premier coup d'oeil tard en
plus de fois le jeu est là que c'est
n'importe quoi alors la première version
du jeu
je mettrai liens se nouent et
télécharger la démo j'aimerais que ça
marchera sur votre ordi moi quand je
lance ça met des couleurs absolument
dégueulasse et c'est absolument pas
beaucoup que vous mettrez quand même au
cas où on va on a défoncé d'amiens ok il
ya combien de filles qui ont fait le
casting pour ce jeu parce que bon c'est
pas que le mec qu'a fait je devais pas
être et je mets quand même donc c'est à
dire à beaucoup trop un massage en
institut tu viens tourner une journée tu
ta fiche dans un jeu vidéo
oh [ __ ] lt lt a été attaqué à un mâle
elle a quand même la grâce à la gamme
l'élégance
on se bat contre oloron rare sur aux
attaques du serpent enchaîné celui d'un
double uppercut pour aulas la merde mais
remet même bien le roi soleil à des
combos de malades à faire non les
connais pas aux tiens tiens tiens
aulas olalalala aurora aurora il fallait
pas que le torrent j'ai failli mourir
bien là allez viens viens ma petite roja
vient là vient pas ici
basic system est bien bon ces derniers
combats là on va pas on va faire une
vidéo de 20 milliards de minutes sur un
jeu comme ça quand même je trouve ça
vaut pas le coup au pire au pire on
finit par un uppercut au les styles les
skis mais la taille que ces reproches et
c'est magnifique confié sur une attaque
en beauté sur à vos claviers je vous dis
à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
même si l'heure d'aller se battre contre
deux familles là où tout le monde puisse
et à bien
oh la vache à lait celle ci au statut
parce que là c'est quand même l'empereur
c'est quand même venus à remonter comme
pas avec vénus yoplait europe j'esquive
as tu as tout si tu veux tu faire avec
de la bise est sûre tu veux faire avec
de la bise
j'aime battre tiens il percute jetant
vols venus retourne d'où tu viens
non maya maya ne fait pas des prières
comme ça ah là là en fait faut jamais
sauté dedans jeu sinon hop et la double
uppercut votre chance manière j'avais
fait entre deux fous j'ai compris
absolument pas alors là bas et où on
voit ce que ça donne alors est-ce qu'on
a gagné oh on allait super récompense
on a là c'est maya robben a annon mais
maya s'est alors voilà ça la gauche 1
c'est pas ce pas les autres [ __ ] mais
les gens qui ont fait ça ils sont quand
même grave
tiens on va oui tiens oh je veux mais la
couronne qui en fait un fil de fer qui
peuvent et ont des similitudes
ouais ou fait la paix tu m'aimes sinon
on est tout seul devant notre écran
c'est pas grave on fait comme si on
était avec toutes ces filles super assez
génial on boit du thé pour fêter ça
[Musique]
salut
tous abattus
c'est le retour du bras de la dernière
fois souvenez vous ce retour il est venu
ici et là